[موسيقى]
فنحن شركه برمجيات المدعومه بالمعدات
لدينا افضل مهندسي البرمجيات من شركات
اوكلوس وسبيس اكس و مايكروسوفت والافضل في
جنوب كاليفورنيا نحن نستخدم الحوسبه
المتقدمه اي ان المعلومات لا تعود الى
كمبيوتر كبير مما يتسبب في بطء العمليه بل
المعدات فيها رقاقه الكمبيوتر مثل تلك
الموجوده في هاتفك وتقوم باغلب العمل على
المعدات مما يقلل المعلومات العائده الى
الشخص المسؤول في حلقه اتخاذ القرار
[موسيقى]
اننا اردنا ان تقوم البرمجيات بالعمل وبلا
شكل لا نريد ان يكون هناك شخص خارج حلقه
اتخاذ القرار فالانسان دائما موجود في هذه
الحلقه لقد تعاوننا مع افضل شركات
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه ذات الخبره في
العالم فنحن لا نبني محركات المروحيات ولا
نبني شفرات المروحيات نحن ناخذ من افضل
الشركات وبافضل قيمه ثم نجمعها مع
مبرمجياتنا من اجل المضيق قدما بسرعه
كبيره جدا
[موسيقى]
حيث نقوم بتحديثها بشكل دوري واسرع بكثير
من قدرات المقتنيات الدفاعيه السابقه
وبالتالي فالدينا اسلوب مختلف للحصول على
برمجياتنا وهو عن طريق الاشتراك الذي يشبه
اشتراكك بخدمه الهاتف السنويه مما يحافظ
على تحديث البرمجيات بشكل مستمر
[موسيقى]